NICO HISCHIER WITH HUGHES LOSE
HANDLE RIGHT
>> Ken: TERRIFIC
FOR THEM.
>> Steve: DEVILS CASHED IN ON
THEIR FIRST POWER PLAY.
HERE'SE OF HUGHES HERE. HOCKEY.
THEY JUS OF OCTOBER.
IN FRONT,
>> Steve:
SECOND ONE, REDIRECT WIDE.
ERIKSSONUT THAT'S A
GREAT SAVE.
AND THEN ONENG.
THE REBOUND.
THEY SCORE!
THE COYOTES THAT
LOOSE REBOUND ON THE HIGH SLOT.
THE INITIAL OPPORTUNITY BY
HERE'S ERIKSSON ON THE
THE
McLEOD SPUN AROUND AND FOUGHT
OFF BY GALCHENYUK.
PUCK
>> Ken: TRANSITION BYROSS
AGAIN.
MOSER WATCHED BYBLACKWOOD.
MAKES A NICE SAVE
QUICK SHOT JERSEY.
A PASS FROM BEHIND>> Steve: IN !
COULDN'T GET A
JOHNSSON.
HE GOES TO THE NET FOR THE
REBOUND AS WELL.
BODIES FLYING
VESEY TRIES TO TURN AND SHOOT.I
INTERCEPT.
3:15 THE PUCK.
HERE'S BRATT AGAIN WITH 1:17 TO